[Music]
the next question is how do we explain
romans 5 14 in the light of resurrection
romans 5 14
says nevertheless
from adam to moses even over them that
had not sinned after the similitude of
adam's transgression who is the figure
of him that was to come
all right well let's read from verse 12
wherefore as by one man sin entered into
the world and death by sin and so death
passed upon all men for that all have
sinned but until the law death was in
the world but sin is not imputed
where there is no no law okay now verse
14 says nevertheless sin reigns from
adam to moses
even over them that had not seen after
the similitude of adam's transgression
what does that mean adam's transgression
was a willful violation of god's law the
bible tells us clearly in first timothy
2 13 14 the woman was deceived the man
was not he sinned willfully cold
noddedly flagrantly deliberately
intentionally he violated god's law
since adam's sin and eve every child who
comes into the world comes into the
world needing salvation so in that sense
death reign over everyone including
those who had not sinned like adam in
other words even the baby in the cradle
needs to be delivered from the
condemnation why because all of us come
with this nature and we have to be
delivered everyone who comes into the
world needs a savior even though we've
been out of sin the way adam did because
a six-year-old baby a six-month-old baby
has to not send away adam's sin because
sin is a moral choice and so that's what
that means not after adam's civility not
willfully with the knowledge of right
and wrong even those who have not gotten
that state they still need a savior
thank you thank you read some questions
from the chat because
james had said
pastor keith since we rise in flesh and
bones and living in heaven i always
wondered if we will have to get rid of
any waste from our bodies as we have to
do in this life
i don't know
i really don't know
i have absolutely no clue the bible
doesn't tell us by the way the person
said we live in heaven we'll only spend
a thousand years in heaven our permanent
home is this earth made brand new so we
talk about going to heaven going to
heaven that's true but it's only a
temporary state christ will come back
after a thousand years destroy the
wicked remake this earth this will be
our permanent home by the way it will
also be the new location of god's
headquarters for the entire universe
this earth but i don't know about waste
disposal i don't
there's nothing in the bible that i know
of that addresses that point when i get
there i'll find out
[Music]